listen I continue to have this very
significant interest in Gavin Newsom as
a possible 2024 Contender if indeed Joe
Biden were to not run for re-election
Gavin Newsom is not the Uber Progressive
candidate that maybe I would dream of
but you go to war with the Army you have
not the Army you wish you had and Gavin
Newsom is doing something very very
important he is accurately concisely and
forcefully
describing some of the obvious lies that
Republicans are telling and that voters
are falling for and I have to tell you
he's using critical language about
Democrats but it is sort of tough love
and Democrats are terrible on messaging
on so many issues this issue of crime in
Democrat states and cities is just a
disaster last week I told you all that
in the Oklahoma
gubernatorial debate
it was correctly mentioned by candidate
Hofmeister that the rate of violent
crime in Oklahoma and Oklahoma City is
higher than the rate of violent crime in
New York state and New York City
respectively and that is absolutely the
case on MSNBC Gavin Newsom interviewed
by a seemingly smitten Alex Wagner who
was just enthralled with what he was
saying as she should be because he is
accurate when he talks about this stuff
saying why aren't we doing better on
this the numbers are on our side it's
not just a messaging Pub but a messaging
problem that has persisted with our
party for years and years constantly on
the defense we allow these cultural Wars
to take shape and we consist in there on
the back end of them eight of the top 10
states with the highest murder rates all
are Republican states yes how did
Democrats not know that in fact it's
really nine out of 10 Georgia went for
Biden but it's really a Republican state
or at least a red State eight out of ten
and we're losing that message crime is
high higher as well as taxes here for
the average citizen in Texas it's higher
crime higher violent crime and poverty
crimes than in the state of California
67 percent higher gun death rate in
Texas why don't we push back I don't
know the answer to that why don't we
push back and remember in my story last
week we looked at some of this data and
one of the things that you see as I
mentioned is that you've got Washington
D.C with a very high violent crime rate
um in 2019 uh and then and also we have
the numbers now for 2020. but you
basically have red States it's Alaska
where violent crime is high New Mexico
is a blue State Tennessee Red State
Arkansas Red State Arizona went Biden
but basically a red State Louisiana
Missouri South Carolina South Dakota
you've got to get down to Michigan
before you get an actual uh another
bluest date and then it's Montana Nevada
Oklahoma Alabama Texas and then you get
to California and then you're almost
halfway done with the list you're almost
at 25. okay it's similar to the repeated
claims that Republicans are good for the
economy they they these are just lies
folks we're going to lower the taxes and
then uh it'll occur encourage investment
and then just everything's going to be
great and the stock market will do well
and unemployment will be low folks go to
the numbers the the numbers aren't
Secret
if you have access to Google you can
find the primary source numbers
overall
the economy does better by the following
metrics under Democrats
unemployment rate is lower
job creation is higher
inflation is lower
GDP growth is higher
stock market returns are higher there's
many others okay now if you want to make
a case that even though the numbers are
better when Democrats are in the White
House it's actually thanks to
Republicans because of either a lag time
which has been debunked or because of
who controls the house mattering more
it's also been debunked or right you
could but you've gotta start with the
data and that's what the data is I like
what Gavin Newsom is doing I like what
Gavin Newsom is saying